[Musique]
il ya un endroit où la vérité est
essentielle même si la plupart des gens
n'y accorde pas d'importance
notre organisation est toujours à la
recherche de ceux qui aiment connaître
la vérité il en prend à en train d'être
ici il sera exécuté
escorté escorté vers la sortie et pour
donner notre approbation nous appliquons
des critères qui peut être considéré
comme mystérieux
monsieur bénédicte nous avons notre
équipe
bonjour
je suis le susnommé monsieur bénédicte
vous avez clairement une qualité dans
notre société manque cruellement rennie
ta compréhension intuitive de la nature
humaine sticky tes connaissances
inépuisable constance la méfiance des
schémas de pensée conventionnelle et
kate un troublant perception de
l'assemblage des choses qu'avez vous
tous les quatre en commun y en a qui ont
peur et
malpoli d'accord seul être capable de
voir la vérité est ensemble vous est
immensément puissant
vous êtes ici pour une mission qui ne
peut être accompli que par des enfants
il y à un sombre individu qui la remet
au cerveau et que cet individu est mon
frère jumeau
[Musique]
vous avez besoin d'une bande d'orphelins
débrouillards pour risquer leur vie en
mission c'est sain pour rester en vie